while their country staggers through an
economic crisis with no end in sight
humans are leaving in unprecedented
numbers
this medical student plans to fly to
Nicaragua before journeying up to the
U.S Mexico border he insisted on
anonymity for fear of reprisals
of the countries for which you don't
need a visa Nicaragua is closest to the
US that's why people fly there he'll pay
five thousand dollars for flights and a
People trafficker or more
either I get there or I die those are my
two options I can accept dying in the
hands of a coyote or during the journey
but I won't die as an old man lining up
for food here in Cuba
he says the islands become a desert most
of his friends have already left and
around half his class we began studying
medicine four years ago has since
vanished those who can leave legally
anadelia Waits while her mum collects a
long-awaited U.S visa when the time's
right she also plans to leave
almost everyone is leaving
in the last six years ramped up U.S
sanctions have hurt the Island's economy
knocking billions of dollars a year off
State revenues
at the same time the post-castro
generation of politicians seems short on
ideas and have been unable to leave
their country out of these economic
troubles
few think things will improve
hopelessness pervades
immigration's been part of the Cuba
story for Generations but that Trends
accelerated since the pandemic a record
number of Cubans emigrated to the US
last year and most young people I speak
to say they'd like to leave too
some Cubans say their islands are prison
without bars and yet if they can make it
to the US's Southern border they have
privileges other Latin Americans don't
enjoy
if a Cuban arrives at the U.S Mexico
border and asks him why he wants to come
to the U.S the classic response is
because I want freedom and human rights
and without providing evidence the
immigration official has the authority
to Grant him entry to the U.S this week
the Cuban government announced more
austerity measures to tackle diesel
shortages
this Mass Exodus has no end in sight Ed
Augustine Al Jazeera Havana
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera